first let me take a selfie
as we reported earlier 45 of americans
have received at least
one dose of the vaccine against the
coronavirus 33 percent are fully
vaccinated
with countries racing to vaccinate their
citizens smiles are appearing online
showing people as they roll up their
sleeves and as roxanna seberry reports
from london
while vaccine selfies may be a new
phenomenon
they're also part of a long tradition
vaccine
vaccine vaccine from dolly singing i'm
begging
you please don't hesitate put that
needle down
to arnold directing and mariah
celebrities are posing for a vaccine
selfie also known as the vacci
in this pandemic awesome thank you
politicians are also posting online
after they roll up their sleeves
and in some cases unbutton their shirts
ministers in greece
france and england have been both teased
the peas calendar and praised for
bearing their humanity parliament
april it's the conservative mp for
basset law brendan clark smith
got a little more publicity than i was
expecting british member of parliament
brandon clark smith says
he was only trying to show the vaccine
is safe
it's just to kind of give people
reassurance why not just roll up your
sleeve
so i wasn't expecting to get the vaccine
so if i was i would have worn a t-shirt
so i probably had to show a little more
flesh than i was expecting
and uh yeah quite hairy as well so i had
a few comments about that too
while covet 19 is the world's first
social media pandemic
using visuals to encourage vaccinations
is an old tradition
take this 18th century engraving of
smallpox vaccine creator
edward jenner inoculating a child
we have this fascinating display of
historic posters
natasha mcenroe of london science museum
says after the polio vaccine came into
use in 1955
one of the greatest triumphs in medical
history is achieved public health
campaigns used multiple forms of media
including photos of the beautiful and
famous to promote it
of course elvis presley being
photographed being administered
the polio vaccine was something that did
have enormous
influence because he was a teen idol
yeah yes for sure and you know it's all
right by elvis it's all right by the
rest of us
in 1976 president gerald ford posed for
his vaccine for the swine flu
in 2009 so did president barack obama
but social media has changed the picture
in the present pandemic
for groups like the british red cross it
posts images of
everyday people getting vaccinated so
this is the early 20th century
which curator mesubin adams says helps
normalize the experience
vaccine hesitancy has existed for as
long as vaccination has existed
by looking at people's real stories it
separates
fact from fiction so people have more
accurate information around vaccines
some critics say the vaccine photo op
can create resentment
after all not everyone has access to a
shot this tiny little vaccine vial
is the the very first but for mcenroe
who's already archiving items from the
covet 19 pandemic
thank you the trend is overall good
you're doing a great job oh thank you it
is a way of unifying us
you know the fact that by by getting an
injection it's not just
protecting myself it's protecting the
community around me
and more importantly perhaps they create
a role in
making some of us smile which i think at
the moment is
is really really important do it
get it over with and she says when
future generations look back on this
pandemic
think you got it i got it okay they'll
see more than just a snapshot
it's the best shot i've ever had of this
moment in history
better than whiskey for cbs this morning
saturday
roxanna seberry london
better than whiskey yes because of what
it provides
right yeah that's right i think jeff
might disagree i know
when i got the second shot i was pulling
up i didn't know it was a drive-through
and it was a little cold
there you go this is actually the first
one yeah these are these are the
perfect muscle shirts i like that i
forgot to include the face and the
selfie
i dressed up for anyway so i was so i
was dr i was it was cold that day so i
had layers and i'm like stripping down
in the parking lot
i'm sure people oh you didn't take that
selfie did you i did not take that